[Musique]
ce sont des jours pour se réjouir, nous
allons tous dans le noir
après la défaite lagertha uber Puran est
parti nous sommes réunis maintenant dépêchez-vous
nous chassions des évasions d'ours grimpez à
un autre arbre parce que vous êtes de retour en
Angleterre
j'ai accepté de vous donner refuge ici si vous
étiez  prêts à se battre avec nous contre
les armées de vos compatriotes
les fils du roi Ragnar lothbrok de notre
côté se sont
préparés à se battre pour nous
soyez très prudent ce que vous dites à propos de David
monsieur que me direz-vous ensuite je n'appartiens pas
ici je veux prendre  que pour
revenir d'en haut
vous ne surmonterez jamais l'attraper je
vais le faire
oh nous avons peur de mourir le
roi Alfred a des ennuis il y a
ceux qui veulent le renverser mais
priez pour qu'aucun de vous ne me trahisse maintenant
nous nous battrons contre frère et le
monde sera
détruit puis-je demander pourquoi es-tu ici maintenant en personne
regarde comme ta place me manque
[Musique]
toi